[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تسميه العرب للايام شهور مبنيه على ما
تتصف او تتسم به فالاسبوع من السبعه وشهر
لشهرته بين الناس والعيد لانه يعود سيرته
الاولى كما بدا والعيد هو اليوم الذي يخصص
للبهجه والسرور والفرح والمسلمين عندهم
عيدين عيد الفطر وعيد الاضحى عيد الفطر
لان الناس تفطر فرحا لاتمام شهر الصوم
ويكون في اول يوم من شهر شوال وعيد الاضحه
لان الناس تاكل فرحا من الاضحيه لاتمام
موسم الحج ويكون في العاشر من شهر ذا
الحجه والعيد بالشرع يوم واحد وبالعرف
ثلاثه ايام للناس عيد ولي عيدان في العيد
اذا رايتك يا ابن الساده تصيد اذا هم
عيدين في سنه كانت بوجهك لي ايام
تعييد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واحتفل المسلمون باول عيد فطر لهم في
السنه الثانيه من الهجره بعد فرض اول صيام
لهم والعيد هالسنه اجوائه معتدله بوجه عام
وبعد ثلاث سنوات نعيد في اجواء ربيعيه
وبعد ست سنوات نعيد في اجواء شتويه ويتسم
عيد المسلمين بسمات اجتماعيه ومعاني
انسانيه راقيه ونادره ففيه تتقارب القلوب
وتجتمع بعد تفرق والعامه يقولون العيد يلم
الاجاويد
[موسيقى]